hi
my name is itamar uh and today I'm going
to be talking about vectorization how
slow python runs fast code
and pythons has a bit of a paradox when
it comes to Performance to running
software quickly
one hand python is slow
it's just and when I say python mostly
I'm talking about the defaults python
interpreter also known as C python since
it's the one almost everyone uses I'm
just going to use them interchangeably
but there are other implementations of
python but most of the time for most
versions python is pretty slow
and python is also a popular language
for scientific Computing data science
and so on
and data processing often involves lots
of data and processing large amounts of
data takes time and you don't want to
wait longer than you need to so you want
your software to be passed
so how do you get fast results from a
slow language
how did python become so popular for
data processing it's easy to use it has
a lot of libraries but being fast enough
to be usable is a minimal requirement so
how did that happen given python is so
slow
and the solution that have people have
come up with uh is known as
vectorization this can be a topic of the
talk today
and the general idea is you can
Implement general purpose operations on
arrays in a faster language arrays might
be two-dimensional one-dimensional quite
a lot of data can be represented as an
array numeric array
you expose these generic operations like
a sum amine and so on in libraries numpy
scipy pandas
and then insofar as you can you can then
use regular python code to assemble
these generic fast functions into more
specialized algorithms
and to see why we might want to do this
it's worth looking at an example
so that's what we want we have a numpy
array we have some large number of
integers or floats we want to calculate
the mean average
and so here are two different ways to do
it
and one we're just going to use pure
Python and we'll do it a little bit like
you would in a lower level language
looking up things by index
so we initialize total we iterate over
values from zero to the length of the
array we add up each individual item in
the array in total and then we divide
the total by the length of the array now
we have the mean of the array
and the other way we can do that is
using numpy's sum function which is a
vectorized function and we'll talk about
what vectorize means specifically as we
go on for the talk
but we have this function that will sum
an array for us and we divide that
resulting total by the length of the
array so in terms of correctness you
don't really care which version of these
you're using right you could use one you
can use the other you're going to get
the exact same results
so either way it really doesn't matter
but
what does make a difference is
when you care about speed so
semantically you don't care but if you
run this on some array that has 30
million integers I generated them
randomly yours hopefully is more meaning
if you use a python for Loop it takes
two seconds if you use a vectorized
numpy.sum function it takes 20
milliseconds so that's 100 times faster
and so you can imagine with a hundred
times speed up you might be going for a
more significant calculation you might
go from something taking an hour and a
half to only taking one minute
this thing takes
hour and a half there's only so many
experiments you can do in a day this
thing takes a minute
you can do far far more attempts to
improve your software you can give
results your users much faster it's just
much much better and like this is really
a
extremely useful
Improvement in speed and sometimes it's
only 20 times or 50 times faster but
it's all the same in terms of
getting these order of magnitude
improvements is a huge benefit in terms
of being able to develop your software
faster give results faster to your users
reduce your compute costs and as a nice
side effects reduce your carbon
emissions if you're operating off
electricity that isn't sustainably
produced
so for the rest of this talk we're going
to dive into uh the problem the solution
which is vectorization and we'll Define
it in a much more accurate way because
there are multiple definitions and they
matter and then we'll talk about some
practical information practical
implications how you can learn what
you've used to write faster code using
vectorization
and we'll start by talking about why
python again this is the default python
representation why python is slow
so imagine you're iterating over a range
object you want to do 0 1 2 3 4 5 and so
on this is a quite common thing to do
especially when you're dealing with
arrays of data you might want to look
things up at different indices
so every iteration every single one of
those numbers gets returned
python will call a function to get the
next value
and here's uh the code the C code for
python interpreter implementation
and so it's doing it's checking if we
hit the end of the range object it's
calling a function called pylon from
long and it's passing in some arguments
so this is doing a little bit of work
outside
in this particular function it's not
doing that much work
but it is more work than uh for example
doing a for Loop in C or some other
language low-level language but it's
still not too bad until we look into
this function pylon from long that's
going to be called on every
uh time we go through the iteration if
we call if we iterate over a million
values where that function is going to
be called a million times
this is what the function looks like and
I use a smaller font because it's uh
quite long and you don't really have to
understand what it's doing the main
point here is that it's doing
decent amount of work and if you pay
attention it's actually calling other
functions along the way
and so what's going on here is that
when we are getting these series of
numbers 0 1 2 3 4 we're using Python's
implemented in C so it's running some C
code to get to those numbers
but python
The Interpreter when it when it creates
an object that you interact with from
python doesn't use C integers it uses
python integers known as pylon objects
and they're a much more complicated
object than what the CPU is using and
then what C is using and so you have to
convert from the C integer along
into a
python integer a pylon object and doing
that conversion is fairly complicated
and so that means just iterating is
going to be slow because we're taking
doing this fast operation of doing a
sequence of numbers and then we're
creating a whole bunch of python objects
and creating python objects is expensive
it has to do a lot of work as to convert
the data from one format to another you
might have to do some allocations
it's not just creating python objects
python integers takes a lot of work
another thing we might want to do in
Python is some math let's say we want to
add two integers
so if you dig into the implementation of
interpreter
this is the entry point function that
adds two integers together
there's actually some work that happens
even just to get to this point I will
just ignore that
so again
this is a fairly complicated function
that's calling other functions and the
reason is in order to add two numbers
together you need to have something that
the CPU understands is a number
and what python has is a pylon object
which is Python's reputation of a number
and so you have to convert from a pi
long object into something the CPU
understands
and that checks work
and so now we're seeing the work in the
opposite direction previously we're
returning a c integer into a python
object now we're turning a python object
into C integer and in order to do any
math we have to do these conversions and
that just adds a lot of overhead
another reason that python is slow is
the way it represents
uh objects in memory and we're talking
about numeric data here we're talking
about arrays so we think about a CRA or
a fortune array
um
the CPU knows about 64-bit integers uh
and in order to have an array we just
put these 64-bit inches errors which are
eight bytes each one after each other in
memory
so the number one two three is eight
bytes and then right after we have
another number four five six another
eight bytes
and so to iterate over these values we
just skip ahead eight bytes at a time
read eight bytes and then we call CPU
instructions if we want to sum these
it's very very fast because it's just
jump ahead eight bytes
call one CPU instruction to some of
these two numbers continue
so this whole memory layout is designed
to match the way the CPU thinks of data
it's designed to be fast
if we move to python however things get
more complicated
if we have a python list of integers
uh it is actually an array and that's
fine that's fast
but it's an array not of integers it's
array of python objects generic python
objects because you can imagine you can
have a list that's an integer integer
than a string python doesn't really know
and so each of those Pi objects is a
pointer to some other location in memory
so first we're going somewhere else in
memory which also takes a little bit of
time
and then we have over there another
object which luckily is a pylon object
it isn't python integer that's 28 bytes
and then we have to as remember recall
convert that back into something that
the CPU can deal with
and so doing something with a python
list of integers involves quite a lot of
work of calling python apis to look up
objects to convert objects
a lot more memory reads and writes which
can be very expensive once you're using
enough data
and it also uses more memory
just as a side effect
sure python is slow uh in large part
because it's converting in between
pythons and memory in memory object
representation and it's a machine
representation back
and interacting with python objects
including lists involves lots of python
apis python does all this because it
wants to make your life easier it might
like to make things uh just more
flexible and so you get all these
benefits of the Python language from
these representations but you also get
the downsides of all these interactions
being slow
so
python is slow we'd like to make things
fast and specifically we want to make
think fast for numeric arrays
which are one of the most commonly used
data structures if you're doing data
processing scientific Computing the like
and the basic idea is that
uh you take a cra
which we saw is nice and efficient of a
specific type for example 64-bit integer
we make a wrapper around it
a python object that wraps around the
CRA so it's just a CRA it's just a low
level array that allows you to do fast
operations and it's just hiding inside a
python trench code underneath the hood
doesn't really have anything python
specific
because of that you can completely
bypass all the python apis python
objects you don't have to worry about
python integers if you want to sum this
array from your perspective it's just
some code that is summing a CRA which we
can do quickly
and then you can do all your fast
operations then when you're done you can
convert it something back into a python
object maybe but it's only the beginning
of the end that you know about python in
between everything that's running really
quickly
uh pandas data frames are implemented
underneath the hood using numpy arrays
there are other python libraries like
numpy that are slightly different in the
end the model they use underneath is the
same one of CRA that is just a thin
thinly wrapped by python
uh and in this context the vector is
just a synonym for array and that's
where the word
factorization comes from
so just to go into more detail of why
this is useful let's say we want to we
have a million integers we want to sum
them
so if we are doing this with a python
list of python integers we're going to
have to read those list items one by one
and actually make sure they're integers
and just reading items in the list
requires calls into the python C API so
we're calling these python c apis a
million times then we get back all these
pylon objects and those pylon objects
aren't saying the CPU could add so we
have to do all this work to convert
those pylon objects and the CPU can
actually add and after all that overhead
then we can finally do some math
so before we get to the math there's
just a huge amount of interacting with
python objects it really isn't helping
us get our answer
let's just work it's wasted work
the other hand we can add up million
integers that are in a numpy array using
numpy's sum function
then the not by some function will say
okay you're a python object but inside
of you you're just a CRA that's hiding
and now I have a CRA and adding numbers
in a CRA is really quite fast like you
just jump ahead a few bytes at a time
it's adding each pair of integers is
just like one CPU instruction
uh and then all the way at the end you
have a sum and then maybe you turn that
into a python object but then you're
just doing one
conversion into a python object instead
of Millions
and so there's just much less overhead
it's much faster
now one thing to keep in mind that just
because you're operating on a whole
array or even just because your code is
written in a low level language it
doesn't mean it's going to be fast it
might still be slow
so we were talking about numpy's sum
function but python also has its own
built-in sum function and we can call
that with
numpy array
and
it will still be slow it's implemented
in a fast language it's operating a
numpy array but it's still slow so why
is that
and the reason is that it's calling back
into python on every item
Python's built-in sum is designed to
work on generic python objects you can
pass in a numpy array but you can also
pass in a python list you can pass in a
python iterator
and so from its perspective it is taking
a sequence of python objects and it is
summing them which means every item
requires you to do stuff with python
apis and it has some specialized code
paths for integers but that's not enough
to override the fact that you still are
calling into python apis like Pi long as
long and overflow and Pi size and pylon
check exact and so on and so forth on
every single item
in the object who passed him whether or
not it's an Empire a python-less it
doesn't matter
Python's built in some function is
calling it to see python apis over and
over and over again
and the result is that it is still quite
slow so if you use a python for Loop to
sum up 30 000 million random integers
that are in a numpy array
Python's built in sum it's a little bit
faster than the for Loop but numpy's sum
function is where you get the benefit of
30 times
uh 50 time Improvement in runtime
because you're actually able to bypass
python altogether
and that leads us to a definition of a
vectorize API and there are two meanings
for vectorize API for our purposes
and differentiating between these is
important because
as we've seen sometimes a thing might
look like it'll be fast but it isn't a
vectorize API might be a bulk API a
function that operates on a whole array
and if it's a bulk API it might also
additionally be a fast API that is an
API that is implemented in a fast
language like crust
and does not call back into python apis
per item
and the first meeting being a public API
is a prerequisite for the second meeting
there's also a third meaning uh called
something called simdi which is jargon
and level programming like C I'm not
going to go into today because of lack
of time but just if you're talking to a
low-level programmer and they talk about
vectorization be aware they might be
talking about something rather different
related but different so just as a side
note
so if we look through our think about
the three ways you've implemented
summing of the array of integers
a python for Loop that just goes through
each item and then adds it to a total
it's written in Python it's not a bulk
API it's not a fast API it's operating
from our perspective on every individual
item and it's certainly not fast it's
very slow
Python's built-in sum function is
written in C and it is a bulk API so in
that sense it's a vectorize API but it's
not a fast API because it calls back
into python for every item
now if you want an API that is both a
bulk API and a fast API
the vectorized API you want is numpy's
sum function because that can just
bypass python altogether
and therefore it can run very quickly
so now that we know what vectorization
is and how allows us to write and how it
makes our good faster and we can think
about some practical implications what
we learned
so first if you are processing large
amounts of data try to avoid Python's
built-in objects like python lists
instead you want to use something like a
numpy array a panda's data frame other
similar libraries all of which we'll use
representations of the data that can be
used efficiently
so for example if you want to
process some data that's in a CSV and
the First Column is some numeric data
some floats you could use Python's
built-in CSV reader and create a list of
floats but then processing that data
will be slow
later on
so instead you're much better off
loading the data in pandas and then you
will have a data frame which underneath
the hood is a numpy array which means if
for example you calculate the mean or
the sum or do other sort of operations
on it you'll be able to use fast apis if
your data isn't in a representation that
is uh you're able to work on efficiently
then you will not be able to do anything
fast so you want to make sure your data
is stored from the start in a fast
representation
condemned by array or something
equivalent
you don't want to iterate over things in
Python just because something is a numpy
array doesn't mean if python for Loop
will be slow we'll be fast doing a
python for Loop over numpy array will
still only very slow so you don't want
to use Python for Loops you don't want
to use list comprehensions you don't
want to use a map
basically anything that iterates over an
object in Python is going to be slow
because it is calling using python apis
it's calling back into python as python
object conversion overhead for every
item you would write over
so instead of iterating in Python you
want to use vectorized apis that do the
iteration internally in a fast language
you also want to avoid calling back into
python
and this can be a little bit harder to
spot
so let's say we have a data frame
uh it's think of it if you're not
familiar you can think of it as a
spreadsheet with columns and so we're
looking at one of the columns in the
spreadsheet so pandas data frame we have
a column called counts and we want to
uh get the absolute counts the counts
might be negative or positive we want to
convert them into uh
positive numbers
so we're using numpy.apps so that's good
it should be a nice fast function
but this operation is not going to be
fast
necessarily
because the map function
accepts a generic python callable
and so it's going to
take
depending on the situation it might be
taking individual items and calling them
on generic python objects one by one by
one
and the specific details might depend on
a specific apis you're using but anytime
you're you're looking at the situation
where you might be calling things item
by item
even if you pass in a fast function if
it's calling that fast function a
million times that's not fast anymore
calling a python API for every item
is going to be slow even if the
underlying function is fast
so instead you want to use a style of
calls where you're passing in the you
know that you're operating on the whole
column or a whole array and you're
passing the whole thing at once into the
vectorize API in this case apps
ABS can operate on both individual items
and on whole arrays and so you want to
make sure using it in the mode where
it's operating in the whole array
because that way you can actually bypass
Python and do the iteration itself and
not have to
have lots of python objects fed to it
but if you're doing things item by item
it will be slow so you want to make sure
even if you're using a fast function
that's not being called for every single
item in your array because then you're
back into the world of slowness
so to summarize if you want to write
fast data processing code don't use
built-in python objects like lists
instead using like a numpy array don't
iterate in Python rely on apis it will
do the iteration for you in a fast
language don't call back into python for
every item because then you undo all the
benefits
you have from running fast code and
instead use bulk fast vectorize apis
operate on numpy arrays or panicom so
the like
so that's why I talk uh you can find the
slides at this address you can email me
I'm on Mastodon
and I should have some time for some
questions now
foreign
thank you very much
yeah
everyone's if everyone's still
processing they're welcome to head to
the Discord uh
are you on the Discord yourself uh I
will be on the Discord in next five
minutes but since we have a few minutes
I can also answer questions here people
put them in the comments
and after that I'll switch to the
Discord
at least I have a couple of comments
thank you
super interesting talk it from Glenn it
really gives me something to think about
while commuting
yeah and a
it's very the most uh
oh I think a common way that people end
up
writing slow code is like forgetting
that you shouldn't be iterating like you
think oh it's in the numpy array so it's
fast but if as soon as you go to for
Loop it gets slow again so that is that
is one of the things we're paying
attention for as you code
uh so the question is how do we if
you're mixing SQL do you want to
minimize Python and uh
uh maximize SQL
uh and then generally yes and this
brings in some additional
related but slightly different uh data
issues so unless you're using some
something like sqlite that's or duct TB
that's built into your process
your database is uh elsewhere it's a
different computer even if it's another
computer you're talking to it over
protocol
and so that takes time for the data to
go back and forth between the database
and your Python program
uh and in any case whether or not it's
like embed a database or remote database
there's also the overhead of converting
from the database representation of the
data into Python's representation and
back and forth so if you get a million
rows from your database
now you have to create a million you
have to convert all the all that data
into something that python can
understand
uh
and then if you then filter it out to 10
rows you've spent all that time
converting the million rows into
something python understands only to
filter it but if you could have filtered
it on the database side then by the time
you need to convert it into python
python understands you have to convert
much less data and you have lower
overhead
uh and there are technologies that
people are working towards that uh might
make this less of an issue but in
general uh minimizing how much data
you're pushing back and forth between
different domains is usually a good idea
yeah
all right thank you very much
any other questions
okay
uh yes sir
X steady shot about avoiding list
comprehensions what alternatives do you
suggest
so the advice isn't necessarily that
list comprehensions are bad if you have
a python list with 100 items in it and
you do this comprehension on it it's
slow but only relatively like you have a
hundred items you're getting over 100
items and the big scheme of things it
doesn't matter
the issue is when you have very large
amounts of data if you have 30 million
entries
then it you know 100 billion entries
like the larger the data the more this
overhead of python adds up and so once
you're dealing with large amounts of
data
anything involving python iteration it
becomes a problem so for small data you
don't think about it like list
comprehension is fine unless you
actually know there's about like for
large amounts of data is when you start
thinking about how do I go faster and
for large amounts of data uh typically
you would replace the list comprehension
with some series of for example numpy
operations on numpy array
because the numpy operations can operate
on the whole area at once and bypass all
the python overhead
so instead of iterating yourself you use
functions that internally are iterating
so if you think about numpy at sum right
numpy.sum is iterating over all the
items in the array
but it's doing it internally in a fast
language and on an efficient
representation
and so anytime you're driving the
iteration
you're doing a for Loop using a list
comprehension using an inefficient
presentation if you allow your numpy or
pandas to drive the iteration and it
doesn't come back into python it'll be
much faster
and you want that once your data is of a
sufficiently large scale for a small
like for day to day I have 100 items in
the list
compound engines are fine